all right we are going to be talking
today about the pandora papers much
requested segment that'll be coming up i
want to start with facebook instagram
and whatsapp because yesterday facebook
and associated owned uh apps and
platforms whatsapp and instagram
suffered a complete and total outage
their worst in a very long time
just hours after
a facebook whistleblower was revealed
and also made some very very disturbing
claims about facebook's
uh awareness about negative influence on
people in society but putting according
to the whistleblower
um profit over
uh society profit over people now are
the two stories connected rampant
speculation that the outage
was deliberately put in place by
facebook to prevent those very platforms
from being used to spread the claims
of the whistleblower the timing is
definitely interesting for sure there's
no denying it um although at this point
in time we don't have anything specific
that would tell us that that's what went
on some people are saying david what do
you need what do you need that's more
specific um let's look at the the two
stories sort of in tandem
first and foremost facebook
whistleblower revealed on 60 minutes
says the company prioritized profit over
public good would not come as a surprise
to many people that that's what facebook
did uh if indeed that is what the
um
whistleblower observed the identity of
the facebook whistleblower who released
tens of thousands of pages of internal
research and documents leading to a
firestorm for the social media company
in recent weeks was revealed on 60
minutes sunday night as francis hagen
the 37 year old former facebook product
manager who worked on civic integrity
issues at the company says the documents
show that facebook knows its platforms
are used to spread hate
violence and misinformation and that the
company has tried to hide that evidence
reminds me of uh exxon mobil knowing in
the 70s the impact on the environment
that their drilling activity had
very similar vibes the thing i saw at
facebook over and over again
was there were conflicts of interest
between what was good for the public and
what was good for facebook and facebook
over and over again chose to optimize
for its own interests like making more
money hagen told 60 minutes 60 minutes
correspondent scott pelly quoted one
internal facebook document as saying
quote we have evidence from a variety of
sources that hate speech divisive
political speech and misinformation on
facebook and the family of apps
are affecting societies around the world
about a month ago hagen filed at least
eight complaints with the sec alleging
the company is hiding research about its
shortcomings from investors in the
public she shared the documents with the
wall street journal which published a
multi-part investigation showing
facebook was aware of problems with its
apps including the negative effects of
misinformation and the harm caused
especially to young girls by instagram
if you're interested in that
specifically check out some of jonathan
heights work on the effect of social
media not just on young people in
general but disproportionately on young
girls something he's worked on quite a
bit
haagen who started at facebook in 2019
is set to testify today before the
senate subcommittee on consumer
protection product safety and data
security i've seen a bunch of social
networks and it was substantially worse
at facebook than anything i've seen
before at some point in 21 i realized
i'm going to have to do this in a
systemic way that i'm going to have to
get out enough documents that no one can
question this is real facebook has
pushed back against reports claiming the
claims are misleading and arguing its
apps do more good than harm so we're
going to get back to that in a moment
simultaneously almost with the
unveiling of this whistleblower
facebook suffering its worst outage
since 2008 pulling down instagram
pulling down whatsapp as well
facebook instagram and whatsapp shut
down for more than six hours on monday
it marked the worst outage for the tech
giant since 2008 when a bug
knocked facebook offline for about a day
but the service had only 80 million
users back then
the outage was caused by quote
configuration changes on the backbone
routers
facebook's vp of infrastructure
santosh ginardin said in a blog post
late monday
as of the writing of this article some
of the services are not yet fully
functioning for example some users are
still reporting problems posting new
content to instagram all three platforms
stopped working shortly before noon when
websites and apps for facebook services
were responding with server errors
reports on downdetector.com showed the
outages appeared to be widespread okay
so
a bunch of interesting things here the
the first thing is again are these two
stories connected did is this a lie is
facebook just straight up lying
and they
pulled down access to their their
platforms
specifically to prevent prevent the
spread of the information about the
whistleblower
i don't know i mean you know this is one
of those things where there are people
who will say obviously not that's
obviously not what happened others who
will say of course that's what happened
this is an outage of this degree is so
rare
um that
the idea that it would just be a
coincidence is essentially impossible um
and then people with opinions in between
i don't know all i can tell you is the
timing is interesting now what was more
interesting is
that
i missed nothing from these platforms
being down
and what i mean by that is okay i was
working i don't really do facebook
during the day
it didn't affect me negatively in any
way that facebook instagram and whatsapp
were down for this period of time now
maybe if it had been a saturday when i
might just be chatting with people on
some of these platforms maybe it would
have been different it did affect our
team we upload content to these
platforms we were unable to do so it
kind of threw for a loop our entire day
but it is very interesting to get
perspective sometimes on the importance
we believe that these apps have and then
what they really have when they are
missing now whatsapp is relied upon in
many countries as the default messaging
app
um and i am on a bunch of whatsapp
threads with people in other countries
argentina and elsewhere
obviously those weren't working i'm not
using that to communicate things of
paramount importance many people are and
it affected them significantly now
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
is using what happened yesterday as an
opportunity to say break these companies
up there's no reason whatsapp should
have to be down because facebook's down
other than facebook bought whatsapp
because it saw whatsapp as a competitor
we will deal with that on the bonus show
but in the meantime let me know your
thoughts do you see the outage and the
whistleblower unveiling as connected or
merely coincidental
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get one hundred percent
of your money back because they stand
behind their product you've got nothing
to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40
off and free shipping when you go to
4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video